the Angelo Lynette's head into the
playoffs for the first time since 2015
what are you feeling right now it's for
sure
that's crazy I don't even know what to
think man give glory to God
[Music]
it's amazing feeling man we got a got a
great group of guys great coaching staff
I think it's the best group to do this
with man there's a lot of our first
times doing it it's gonna be a blast I'm
excited you talked all along to
teammates to talk about you weren't
concerned about getting help to get into
the postseason you wanted to do it
yourselves you guys go out win
back-to-back games on the road for the
first time since 2014 you talk about the
hunger at this group had to get it done
your way we knew it is not safe honestly
we knew what we had to do we knew how
we're gonna come together collectively
and do it as a group and that's the
outcome for the result was what we
deserve honestly I think I think we
played the way guys put in the work this
summer this is the result you came out
had a strong performance last night
another strong performance I'm asked
again what does this mean to you to get
to this point
postseason bound guy man it's all guys
like I said we got the best group to do
it my brother's we're brothers man in
and we knew what it was gonna take early
going into this season we knew how hard
it was gonna be teams counted us out
people counted us out but now we there
so we two feet in we're not looking back
on this one enjoy Oh three sections
Bert Michael something real